[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa el numeral free
britney era visto inicialmente como una
teoría conspirativa en internet pero
pronto se convirtió en un movimiento que
ha llegado hasta el capitolio de eeuu la
campaña que empezó pidiendo la libertad
de la cantante britney spears quien
durante 13 años ha estado bajo una
figura legal que controla su vida y su
dinero ahora ha arrojado luz sobre los
abusos que se cometen bajo la llamada
curaduría o conservar el 7 en la que se
encuentran al menos 1.3 millones de
estadounidenses empezamos
en 2019 los fans de britney spears se
enteraron de que la cantante había sido
ingresada a un centro de salud mental
tras desaparecer de la escena pública y
haber cancelado un esperado show en las
vegas especularon que estaba siendo
retenida allí en contra de su voluntad e
impulsaron una campaña en internet
llamada freeborn y que traduce liberen a
britney todo empezó en binnish grant un
podcast dedicado a discutir sobre las
publicaciones de la princesa del pop en
instagram los usuarios sugerían que
últimamente la cuenta de whitney en esta
red social no estaba siendo administrada
por ella y que a través de sus
fotografías estaba enviando un mensaje
oculto pidiendo ayuda freak whitney que
era visto como una teoría conspirativa
se convirtió rápidamente en una forma de
presionar públicamente a la justicia
para que la libere de su padre quien
comparte una tutela legal que controla
las finanzas y la vida personal de
britney desde hace 13 años
pero más allá de exponer la realidad de
britney spears este movimiento ha puesto
el foco sobre este tipo de tutelas
legales en eeuu conocidas como
curadurías o conservar los jets sobre
las cuales se habían denunciado antes
numerosos casos de abuso el documental
del new york times' frame in vain spears
detalla la contienda legal que la
cantante mantiene con su padre para que
éste no sea su tutor durante una
audiencia a finales de junio
britney denunció que además de ser
medicada aislada de sus amigos y de
haber sido obligada a trabajar sin
descanso tiene prohibido retirarse un
dispositivo intrauterino para que no
pueda tener hijos aunque en gran medida
es legal que las personas bajo esta
tutela no puedan tomar sus propias
decisiones
activistas movimientos feministas y
organizaciones defensoras de derechos
humanos como human rights watch y la
unión estadounidense por las libertades
civiles califican esta figura como
abusiva y la define como una violación a
los derechos y las libertades civiles
pero cómo funciona la tutela legal o
conservar josep ésta varía según el
estado y en california por ejemplo
cuando la justicia considera que alguien
no tiene la capacidad de administrar sus
propios asuntos
a una persona oa una organización para
que se encargue de sus finanzas o de su
cuidado personal los protegidos son en
general adultos mayores o personas con
discapacidades mentales o físicas el
curador puede ser un familiar un amigo o
un profesional designado por la justicia
cualquier persona relacionada con el
caso puede pedir la anulación de la
tutela y el protegido debe demostrar su
capacidad para manejar sus propios
asuntos después de ello el juez tomaría
una decisión
según britney ella misma ignoraba que
podía ser tal solicitud su padre su
tutor desde 2008 luego de la recordada
crisis que sufrió el artista y que
generó preocupaciones sobre su salud
mental sus diagnósticos nunca se han
hecho públicos y se cuestiona cómo es
que alguien de su edad con 39 años haya
sido puesta bajo tutela legal por
considerarse la incapaz pero si se asuma
que es competente para trabajar con
normalidad como lo ha hecho durante la
última década lanzando álbumes haciendo
presentaciones en vivo y giras mundiales
la discusión sobre el caso de britney no
sólo ha sido impulsada por los fans de
la artista y celebridades
internacionales sino que también ha
llegado hasta el capitolio de eeuu el
senador republicano por el estado de
texas de cruz dijo que le parecía un
abuso del sistema judicial el líder de
la mayoría demócrata en el senado chuck
schumer dijo que el congreso debería
mirar leyes para hacer algo al respecto
por su parte la ex aspirante demócrata a
la presidencia y senadora por el estado
de massachusetts elizabeth warren señaló
que el caso de britney muestra las
antiguas brechas sobre el sistema de
tutelas que puede dejar a las personas
vulnerables al abuso y a la explotación
y por ello pidió al departamento de
salud y servicios humanos y el
departamento de justicia revisar estos
problemas situaciones como ésta
inspiraron la película de netflix
llamada descuida yo te cuido que trata
sobre como tutores legales se aprovechan
de sus protegidos para lucrarse según
cifras oficiales alrededor de 1.3
millones de personas en el país están
bajo este tipo de tutelas lo que
representa un total de 50 mil millones
de dólares en activos bajo control de
terceros
el caso de britney spears está en cada
portal informativo alrededor del mundo
por la figura que ella representa pero
también ha llevado a los medios de
comunicación de algunos países a
analizar cómo funcionan las tutelas
legales en sus respectivos territorios
en mexico el portal animal político
titula si fue ni fuera mexicana y agrega
que en su país la cantante enfrentaría
los mismos o quizás más obstáculos que
en eeuu criticando la interdicción como
se le conoce a la figura de tutela y la
legislación mexicana el semanario
francés l'express titula que como
britney spears hay 800 mil adultos bajo
tutela en francia y que entre estas
cifras hay casos de abusos varios medios
británicos han destacado la diferencia
de la tutela estadounidense con la que
existe en reinounido que a su juicio es
más transparente la emisora el vice cita
la opinión de una abogada que dice que
una curaduría como ésta sería rara en el
país
hasta aquí revista digital recuerda que
si quieres repetir esta u otra visión de
nuestro programa lo puedes hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
francia 24 puntos